is there um with Al-Qaeda or in general
is there a language barrier too it could
be just barriers of different
communication Styles I mean you got like
a New Yorker way about it
that might make somebody from like
I don't know Laguna Beach
do you feel that language barrier and
communication is
um that language and communication style
in itself creating a barrier you got a
barrier when you think that your way is
the way sure that's the biggest barrier
yeah like and that happens all the time
um when people talk about what about
cross-cultural negotiations
you know uh what hand do I gotta shake
hands with sure so that I can get my way
[Music]
well if you strip it all down we're all
we're all basically the same blank slate
when we were born we gotta everybody's
got a limbic system everybody's limbic
system works pretty much the same way
people are driven by the same sorts of
decisions how does this affect my future
one of my risk of losing how does this
affect my identity you know kind of
kidnapper
you're a New York City businessman
you're a tobacco Farmer in the south all
making those same same decisions based
on those same things
so as soon as I start to navigate that
and
I tailor my Approach which is what
empathy is to what you think how you see
things
so I can be
the biggest goofball ever from
if you live in the south yeah maybe I'm
a New Yorker or I'm somebody from LA or
somebody from Chicago
but my geography is foreign to you but
as soon as I start dialing in on how you
see things
suddenly you're listening
what about the three voices you talk
about the different voices you can use
in that communication right the
assertive Voice direct and honest
I'm a natural born assertive
Natural Born I thought we're all Blank
Slate it's your boy stop catching me on
what I said how dare you through accuse
me of what I've said to quote Bono I
Stand Accused of what I've said the
things I've said it's a good line he's
got a few good lines yeah so assertive
voice you're born that way which one uh
what are the other ones uh analyst
you're an analyst and I can tell you're
assertive
yeah what's an analyst voice
well an analyst is close the smarter
more thoughtful
no as a matter of fact
look you ever do a decision tree yeah
see you like it too don't you
so decision trees you know there's I'm a
computer scientist so we have I like
mathematical uh systematic ways of
seeing the world it's an analyst
you think Donald Trump would ever say
that
unlikely
well is he more the assertive kind he's
a natural born assertive yeah yeah
are all New Yorkers like this is this
someone something in the water no that's
a crazy thing I mean there's an affect
that a city can have yeah
and um you know New York's Northeast not
just New York
but the Northeast is is a little more
the the the affect yeah of the area of
the culture of the area the individuals
individuals still boil down into the
three types cross-abort what's the third
one
um accommodator smiling optimistic
hopeful yeah I'm 100 a thousand percent
convinced that the phrase hope is not a
strategy
is designed at people's frustration over
a third of the population being
accommodators that are hope driven
I hope this works out
and they're very relationship they on
the surface they're very relationship
oriented they tend to appear to be very
positive and they are
but it's really built around hope and
the idea is you can adopt these three
voices you can yeah you can learn them
they're all learnable
the analysts
are often mistaken for accommodators
because as you said before
you know analysts are more introspective
more analytical
they're looking at the systems at work
and
if
um if they like to learn
they notice
that accommodators make more deals than
they make they also notice that there's
a higher failure rate of the deals
but since they notice stuff and they
think about it
they catch on faster than asserters do
that the pleasant nature of an ant of an
accommodator contributes strongly to
them making deals
like my daughter-in-law
um is an analyst you know another
another descriptor we have in that an
analysts are assassins
you know an analyst will snap you from a
thousand yards out in the middle of the
night
and you never know what hit you and
they're really happy with that
but uh has how has assertiveness the
assertive voice served you in
negotiation poorly
that's the sort of voice
is almost always counterproductive it
feels like getting hit in the face with
a brick
and that's almost always
counterproductive so for me to be more
effective especially in a negotiation
I'll need to slow slow down
and smile
you know I heard that uh Teddy Roosevelt
was a good negotiator and then he was
extremely stubborn
and perhaps the right term for that will
be assertive but he picked his battles
is there some value to
holding strong to principles so I don't
even know if that's probably the
opposite of empathy are there times when
you can just stick
be extremely stubborn to your principles
we do it all the time we just you know
we're just nice about it okay it helps
to be nice you're saying well yes
because I need you to hear me and the
assertive tone of voice
so when when we do our training
typically we do an exercise called 60
seconds so she dies
and I play the bad guy bank robber and I
ask you to be the hostage negotiator
and your job is to I'll give you the
four cons real world constraints
and then you got to try and negotiate me
out of the bank now we're doing this now
the first voice that I always use in
that exercise is The assertive's Voice
which is the commanding voice
it's the voice that all police officers
are taught to use in the street
issued loud and clear commands
you know it doesn't it to me I don't
feel like I'm attacking you
I just feel like I'm being direct and
honest and clear
you on the other hand feel attacked
now with doing this exercise in Austin
a couple of years ago the first
participant has an Apple watch on
he tells us afterwards
that's sitting still
not even answering
when he first gets hit in the face with
the assertive's voice his heart rate
jumped to 170. which is a typical fight
or flight reaction I come at you like
I'm fighting you
your your fight flight mechanism all
kick into gear which clouds you're
thinking you're automatically Dumber in
the moment
so if I want to make a great long-term
deal with you
highly profitable
I'm agnostic to you being profitable is
that you'd be profitable that's fine I'm
here to make money for me
making you dumber will always hurt me
me making you feel attacked
will always hurt me
so there's never a value in being in you
making me
afraid
there's never a long-term value in it